today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens supplement your health
and nutrition with their daily blend of
vitamins and minerals more on them in
just a bit
she was described as the most beautiful
woman in hollywood's nay
the world she could enthrall audiences
simply with her gaze or by parting her
lips just enough to reveal the endless
possibilities of sin her life had all
the markings of a modern day fairy tale
the story of a princess who made her way
through life thanks to her beauty only
to find herself locked in the castle of
a warlord a captivity from which she
would escape to conquer hollywood but
nobody would suspect that this
austrian-born star had the brains of a
world-class inventor she was the screen
siren who inspired catwoman and disney
snow white and who invented the
technology that would later enable wifi
and bluetooth today the story of hedy
lamarr
[Music]
the actress later known as hedy lamarr
was born hedwig kissler on the 9th of
november 1914 in vienna she was the only
child of a mill and gertrude trude
kisler both parents were part of the
wealthy assimilated viennese jewish
community and were able to provide
hedwig with the best education trude
introduced the young eddie to classical
music theater and the arts in general
she was enrolled in one of the best
schools in the austrian capital the
doblinger middle school which could
boast anna freud daughter of sigmund as
a teacher however pre-teen heady had
other concerns beyond the liberal arts
she had a knack for taking things apart
to understand how they worked and
reassembling them again afterwards a
pastime which delighted a mill who was
supportive of her early engineering
endeavors but most of all hedy was
conscious of her beauty and how she
would turn heads wherever she went she
also had an unruly spirit that her
parents did their best to keep under
control
failing consistently for example one of
hedy's grandmothers died when she was
12. as her parents were distracted by
the funeral arrangements the tween
seized the moment to enter a beauty
contest which he won around the same
time the kisslers decided to lock the
rebel girl in a swiss boarding school as
if that would work eddie asked her
friends to cable the school pretending
to be her dad demanding she return home
the ruse worked and eddie slipped back
to vienna to attend yet another pageant
by her early teenage years the young
kissler was back in vienna igniting the
passion of older boys and dating for the
first time one of them was a 21 year old
actor wolff albacheretti later to become
father of another austrian star remy
schneider this period is also when
hedwig took her first steps to stardom
first she signed up for acting classes
then got herself a job as a script clerk
at sasha's film studios austria's
largest movie production company she
should have been at school but she
forged a note in her mother's name to
leave class and attend the interview
while working there eddie learned that a
casting call was being held for the
minor role of a secretary so she stole
some makeup from another aspiring
actress and gave herself a bit of a glow
up looking more stunning than ever had
he boldly told the assistant director i
want to play the part of the secretary
and so it was that she got her first bit
role in gold on the street released in
1930. the small part attracted the
attention of max reinhardt a director
with legendary credentials this wizard
of theater cast her in the stage comedy
the weaker sex with a part so small it
didn't even have a name the character
was credited only as first american but
reinhardt uttered some magic words to a
group of reporters saying hedy kissler
is the most beautiful girl in the world
the quote was picked up by trade papers
in october of 1931 the spell had been
cast and the future star received more
offers for cinematic work hedwig moved
to berlin where she shot two films in
rapid succession the trunks of mr of and
we don't need money hedy played similar
characters in both movies a sweet
unglamorous young woman who is able to
defend herself with powerful slaps
should the need arise contemporary
critics found her acting just competent
enough but obviously everybody agreed on
her magnetic beauty hedy had enjoyed
relative success in berlin but in
february 1932 she decided to leave the
city many fellow jewish performers had
taken the same decision sending an
imminent rise to power of the nazi party
and they moved to vienna one star
however had other motivations she had
been hired by czech director gustav
mahati to act in the film that would set
europe ablaze with controversy
ecstasy
[Music]
photography for ecstasy began in july
1932 taking place on the carpathian
mountains had he played the part of eva
a young woman married to an older man a
mill who turns out to be impotent eva
leaves him and decides to reconnect with
nature by swimming nude and alike there
she meets the young engineer adam and
the two fall in love mahati's intention
was to present the heroine as a
modern-day eve who reconnects with the
garden of eden where she meets her adam
the main character is presented as an
independent young woman who rejects the
gilded cage built around her by a
decaying husband in doing so she becomes
a life-affirming force never ceding
authority to other male figures not even
to adam along the way mahathir and hedy
earned a misleading reputation for
pornography there is in fact a nude
swimming sequence and a close-up of
eva's face during orgasm all tamed by
today's standards but not in the 1930s
the star was initially fine with those
scenes but when x to see premiered in
vienna in february of 1933 she was dead
embarrassed nonetheless ecstasy was
becoming a wild success propelled by
scandal and controversy on one hand
traditional conservative cinema-goers
found this tale of extra-marital sex
disturbing and disgusting on the other
hand everybody else found the nudity and
the orgasm sequence to be too tame the
marketing campaign for the flick
promised all sorts of obscenity and not
some kind of art house film with just
one shot of a naked girl to them that
was the scandal in any case all this
publicity could only serve hedy's goals
she was now the talk of european cinema
and another contract soon ensued in
march of 1933 when she got the lead role
in a stage production about empress
[ __ ] an iconic figure of austrian
culture her performance was greeted with
enthusiasm by critics who for once
praised her skills instead of just her
looks if this is the story of a fairy
tale we could say that this is when our
protagonist is recognized as princess of
her realm but this was also the moment
in which the princess met a dark and
shadowy figure who would become her
captor fritz mandel now just before we
get into the rest of today's video quick
word from athletic greens today's video
sponsor athletic greens is a
comprehensive all-in-ones greens powder
engineered to fill the nutritional gaps
in your diet and support your body's
nutritional needs across four pillars of
health gut health immune support energy
and recovery it's packed with 75
right here vitamins and minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients combining
the perfect amounts of micronutrients
absorption and taste to jumpstart your
daily routine you would be hard pressed
to find a more comprehensive powder or
supplement on the market now let you
guys know not exactly a fitness youtuber
you're not coming to my channel for
squat tips but i do like to eat right
take care of myself but i also know
there's gaps in my diet i don't get all
the vitamins but i do with athletic
greens
you just put one scoop in the water
bottle you shake it up in the morning
and you're all good for the rest of the
day plus it's gluten free dairy free
paleo vegan keto low allergy and low
calorie there's less than one gram of
sugar per serving one of the things i
like about it it's kind of gives me a
sustained feeling of energy i have my
coffee in the morning i put down some
athletic greens green powder with it and
i don't know if it's placebo but i do
feel better maybe i just feel better
about myself having something healthy
with the copious amount of coffee that i
drink but whatever athletic greens is
the perfect dietary support regimen so
if that sounds like something you've
been looking for you can grab your own
immunity bundle that's a year of vitamin
d plus you get these five additional
travel packs with your first purchase at
athleticgreens.com forward slash
biographics again year supply vitamin d
buy free travel packs at athletic
greens.com forward slash biographics or
just click the link in the description
below and now back to today's video
fritz mandel came from a wealthy
hungarian family he had been born out of
wedlock in february of 1900 from a
jewish father and a catholic mother the
two married only when the boy was 10. an
ambitious man mandel made it big in the
armament's business earning the
nicknames of austria's munitions king
and the merchant of death pritz was also
elegant charming and a smooth talker he
nagged mercilessly hedy and her parents
until the kistlers consented to an
engagement announced in may 1933. hedy
converted to roman catholicism and the
two were married on the 10th of august
1933 soon embarking on a honeymoon
across europe's most luxurious
destinations venice capri nice
paris all along the young bride had a
taste of the riches that this marriage
could offer but she soon realized that
those solid gold bracelets weighed more
than handcuffs as she later put it at
every luxury except freedom in fact
fritz was blinded by a furious jealousy
he demanded that he quit acting and
ensured that she did not get access to
the movie and staged celebrities it was
rumored that he ordered every print of
ecstasy to be bought and destroyed the
rumor was probably a publicity stunt
concocted by the director mcatee but it
captures mandel's character well after
the honeymoon the munitions king locked
up his princess in his version of
rapunzel's tower villa fiegenberg about
160 kilometers outside of vienna mandel
demanded that hedy spend all her time at
home and not attend any social or
business events he even ensured that she
was always short on cash to better
control her a battle of wit soon ensued
as the princess bride staged crazy
antics to escape pritz's control on one
occasion she removed all 16 toilet seats
from the vast mansion repainted them in
bright colors and sat them out to dry on
the front lawn this was happening just
when fritz's business partners were
arriving for a meeting she then took to
escaping from the villa and going on
wild shopping sprees buying on credit of
course when fritz saw the extent of the
bill he agreed to give her a fixed
allowance one day after escaping to
vienna had he realized that fritz was
following her in her own version of
events she evaded capture by sneaking
into a notorious people show club but
she entered the wrong door and found
herself on stage with the performers
having no other options eddie got into
character and improvised performance
with a young male actor it's often said
that life imitates art in this case
hedy's life seemed to follow the plot of
ecstasy a young wife older husband and
extramarital passion one of the such
flings was inadvertently caused by a
friend and client of mandals a former
italian journalist you might have heard
of this chap it's benito mussolini
mussolini was happy to buy weapons at a
premium rate from mandel he knew that
fritz could use the extra cash to fund
count ernst von stehenberg one of the
top most austro-fascists and a leader of
the heimther militia ernst happened to
have a charming younger brother
ferdinand who caught hedy's eye and the
two started an affair in the meantime
mandal was busy supporting the local
brand of fascism while he was opposed to
an annexation by german nazis mandel
shared much of their ideology including
anti-semitism in fact in 1936 the
austrian association of cinema producers
declared a ban on hiring jewish
performers this may have prompted
eddie's plan to elope with ferdinand on
the 13th of november 1936 the two hopped
on a train to budapest where had he
planned to resume acting in theater but
when the train pulled into the station
eddie was shocked to see fritz waiting
for her his face was a grey mask of fury
mrs mantle was promptly returned to her
gilded cage but it didn't take long for
her next prison break in early 1937 hedy
hired a new may laura her credentials
she made for a credible lookalike one
morning the runaway bride slipped three
sleeping pills into laura's coffee after
she fell asleep eddie donned her uniform
packed a suitcase and snuck out from the
servant store driving laura's wreck of a
car had he made it to a nearby train
station and hopped on a train to freedom
the experience with mandel had not been
entirely negative while she was supposed
to play the role of a trophy wife at
business gatherings she actually enjoyed
discussing technical details with
mandel's colleagues especially engineers
what everybody had overlooked so far is
that ms kessler may have frequently
skipped school but when she was in class
she excelled at science her propensity
for experimenting and inventing would
later pay off in a rather unexpected way
the mandel's marriage was dissolved
years later when hedy obtained a divorce
in nevada after leaving the states her
first destination was similar at
switzerland a popular destination
amongst jewish showbiz personalities
seeking refuge from germany and austria
while there the princess on the run had
a brief affair with eric maria remark
also a persona non grata due to his
novel all quiet on the western front but
the two soon parted ways and mrs kusla
reached london in the summer of 1937.
this is where she was introduced the man
who would open the gates of hollywood
for her co-founder of mgm louis b mayer
the film tycoon was interested including
her in his new batch of imported
european talent he was also aware of the
fame that she gathered thanks to ecstasy
and was quick to admonish her he said
never get away with that stuff in
hollywood never a woman's
is for her husband not theatergoers
mayer also picked a new name for his new
acquisition kisler sounded too german
and mandel had political connotations
from now on she would be known as hedy
lamarr after the late silent film star
barbara lemar on october 4th 1937 the
reborn miss lamar signed her first
contract with mgm with a weekly salary
of 550
about 10 000 in today's money despite
plenty of attention from the gossip
columns hedy still struggled to find a
suitable role she spoke little english
and some camera tests convinced mgm
directors that she really could not act
that was until producer walter wagner
had an insight with her dark hair wide
eyes and foreign accent lamar was an
embodiment of exotic beauty perfect
casting for exotic dramas and so she got
to star in 1938's algiers are all
coveted by ingrid bergman in this drama
set in algiers casbah lamar plays the
role of a passionate woman torn between
an older husband and her young lover a
gangster what a surprise a review of the
time read best of all is the smoldering
velvet voiced wanton mouthed femme
fatale blackhead hazel-eyed viennese
actress hedy lamarr suddenly our heroine
had broken into the fantasies of
millions of american cinema goers her
looks even inspired the character design
of sydney's snow white initially drawn
to be blonde later she would also
inspire the first version of catwoman
the success of algiers was followed by
lady of the tropics in 1939. in this
romance set in saigon hedy plays a
multi-racial woman born to a french
father and an indochinese mother and
guess what she's torn between an older
powerful industrialist lover and a
younger suitor surprise
another pattern that emerges is that mgm
was typecasting heady into stereotypical
roles the trend was confirmed by 1942
with white cargo here the austrian
beauty plays another exotic seductress
the half egyptian half arabic ton de
laio these films did do well enough at
the box office but lamar would later
regret not sinking her perfectly aligned
teeth into meatier roles for example in
1940 she had turned down the classic
thriller gaslight even worse in 1942 she
had to decline the part of ilsa in
casablanca for contractual reasons the
role went to ingrid bergman of course
[Music]
during her early tinseltown years hedy
lamarr married and soon divorced two
hollywood personalities first the
producer jean markey with whom she
adopted her son james then she married
actor john loda with whom she had two
children denise and anthony all the
while she maintained a hobby only a few
friends such as howard hughes were aware
of designing inventions hughes gifted
her portable engineering equipment so
that she could invent away in her
trailer between takes had he repaid the
favor by streamlining the tycoon's
racing airplane lamar also invented a
tablet that could turn a glass of water
into a cola drink she also invented an
anti-aircraft shell with a proximity
fuse after the u.s entered world war ii
in december 1941 she wanted to do more
for the war effort together with a
friend composer george anthel she
developed an idea building on frequency
hopping a concept originally patented by
nikola tesla in 1903. lamar reasoned
that naval torpedoes were given input
for both depth speed and direction but
were left unguided after launch how
about developing a technology to control
their trajectory remotely hedy went one
step further how could one prevent the
enemy from jamming those directions
given via radio signals with the help of
anthiol an expert in mechanical pianos
she devised a contraption similar to a
piano role that would switch between ata
frequencies very hard for the enemy to
intercept this method was patented on
august 11th 1942 under the name secret
communication system the invention was
fully developed by the u.s military in
1959 as a device to control early drone
models three years later during the
cuban missile crisis all u.s navy
vessels to enforce a blockade on cuba
were equipped with the technology and
jumping even further ahead the lamar
anthill secret communication system
became a fundamental component of
wireless communication systems including
wi-fi and bluetooth this invention alone
was estimated to be worth at least 30
billion dollars in today's money and yet
hedy and george never saw a single cent
the sad truth is that the navy rejected
the invention back in 1942 they
understood its theoretical advantages
but found it to be too cumbersome to put
into practice and in later years lamar
failed to renew the patent application
during the war years the armed forces
believed that eddie lamar could serve
her country of adoption in another way
she bolstered the morale of gi joes by
joining uso events and more importantly
led a fundraising effort which sold 25
million worth of war bonds in just 10
days
[Music]
with her contract with mgm expired she
invested heavily in producing her own
movies the noir the strange woman of
1946 was a moderate success but
dishonored lady one year later was
savaged by censorship and tanked at the
box office this did not help eddie's
finances as she was known for reckless
shopping sprees the 1940s though closed
with hedy's biggest success to date the
biblical epic samson and delilah
directed by cecil b demille and starring
victor mature as the male lead
commenting on mature's pictorials
groucho marx famously quipped first
picture i've seen in which the male lead
has bigger than the female as much as we
love groucho barks and his humor we
expect that lamar wished to be
remembered for something more than a
figure but such was the life of a
hollywood star and one on the decline
too at the age of 35 movie offers
started to dry up after working with
demille had he only appeared in six more
films the last being the female animal
in 1958 hedy's declining years were
accompanied by trouble and heartache at
home throughout the 1950s and 1960s
eddie got married and then divorced
three more times the wild spending the
box office bombs and the divorce lawyer
bills left the once glamorous star
financially ruined in 1965 she confessed
to a fan i have no idea where my next
meal is coming from and some days i go
hungry in 1966 she had the chance to
return to the screen with the horror
picture mummy dead but she first failed
to show up on set and when she did she
collapsed due to exhaustion in february
she was fired from the production the
year 1966 was the start of a series of
curious appearances in court earlier
that january she'd been arrested for
shoplifting however the judge found her
innocent and released her in the
following years she appeared in court
again and again this time as the
plaintiff first she sued the
ghostwriters who had penned her 1966
autobiography ecstasy and me and accused
them of inventing scandalous details and
lurid stories then in 1974 she dragged
to court comedy legend mel brooks guilty
of naming a character hedly lamarr in
his blazing saddles apparently brooks
was amused by the attention and agreed
to settle out of court next up were the
newspapers san francisco chronicle and
the national enquirer the chronicle the
dead publishing the photo of a
two-headed goat called hedy lamar while
the latter claimed that the once star
had become a pathetic recluse old and
ugly by the 1990s hedy was living in a
small flat in miami supporting herself
with a social security check and a
screen actors guild pension she was
arrested again for shoplifting in 1991
and this time she was sentenced to a
year of probation in april 1998 eddie
found the energy to file her final
lawsuit against software company coral
corp her photo had been used without
permission on the cover of coral draw
[Music]
hedwig kissler better known as hedy
lamarr died on the 19th of january 2000
in castlebury florida up to the end she
kept coming up with new inventions a
fluorescent dog collar a type of new
traffic light and even improvements for
the concorde in her last years eddie had
become obsessed with plastic surgery
some say she was attempting to recreate
her long gone beauty true hedy owed her
success and film career to her looks but
deep inside she despised them in her
autobiography she wrote my face has been
by misfortune it has attracted all the
wrong people into my boudoir and brought
me tragedy and heartache for five
decades my face is a mask i cannot
remove i must always live with it
i curse it perhaps that's what she
wanted to do through surgery punish and
erase the face that had distracted the
world from her true talents a gift for
innovation invention and inexhaustible
lust for life she once said when i die i
want on my gravestone thank you very
much for a colorful life the actual
quote in our gravestone represents much
better heady's world view and
achievements films have a certain place
in a certain time period technology is
forever i hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and thank you for watching
[Music]